you
the European credit transfer and
accumulation system has been running now
for over 25 years and it was originally
established to help students transfer
credits for the learning that they had
done in one University to another in
another country but now it's turned into
a tool which is helping universities to
modernize their education as a whole and
really focus it on the needs of
individual students a CTS is for all
students you know full-time part-time
lifelong learners they can all benefit
from a CTS mobile students can use it
yes for the recognition of their periods
of study abroad and of their
qualifications credits can be obtained
in the institution where the student is
registered either permanently or
temporarily the CTS credits have become
the currency of European higher
education
students benefit from this because it
really puts them in control of their
program they are the ones who can choose
the modules which fit together
in order to make up their course and
really reinforces the concept of
student-centered learning ect s
credits are used for all sorts of
educational programs including online
distance courses and for all kinds of
students higher education institutions
benefit from ECT s because it helps them
to design programs which are as
efficient as possible and which are
really targeted on the range of learning
outcomes which the students need to
achieve by using the CTS programs are
well structured and well described so
they become more transparent to the
outside world with 60 credits for every
academic year and a clear approach to
how you define learning outcomes it
means that degrees are much more
readable between countries helping with
both the mobility of students and staff
and with the broader
internationalization of universities
the guide is for students themselves so
that they understand what's expected of
them it's for teachers to help them
deliver their programs more effectively
and it's for stakeholders on the outside
like employers for example to understand
better what it is that students have
achieved during their program of study a
guide takes you through all the steps
that you need to run a CTS in your
institution it helps with the design of
a program to make sure that you have
clear learning outcomes and a balanced
workload for students it helps you with
the evaluation of the achievement of the
learning outcomes by the students
themselves and finally it helps you to
ensure that the credits are recognized
when a student moves from one University
to another over 75% of all of the
courses which are delivered in higher
education in Europe already use DCTs and
I hope that the guide will help to
increase that number even more
you